wake up java the bow don't sweat now
peace well
you got it's a beautiful day gonna burn
my troubles away I'm going
the time
covered factions mods and the history of
Fallout itself but we haven't talked
about the heart of the game yet the
people even though most the population
died way before you to end up either in
the nuclear bombings or as a result of
horrific experiments there are still
plenty more to chat to listen to and
kill horribly as the game goes on
fallout just wouldn't have been fallout
with some of the most memorable
characters in the wasteland Sentinel
Sarah Lions Alistair Tenpenny vest oh
they were all part of the experience
here's our pick of the five most
influential characters across the
Fallout series it wouldn't have been the
same without them remember she's all
that the teen movie in which the lesson
is always be not ugly who did the best
out of that film yes Freddie Prinze jr.
married Buffy but the real answer is the
DJ guy because that guy grew up to be
usher in the fallout universe usher is
non-canon unless he can survive nuclear
explosions but we still have three dogs
the wastelands best and most influential
DJ and radio host on galaxy news radio 3
dog is on a one-man mission to
counteract the enclaves propaganda
machine through the medium of news blues
and things to amuse if it wasn't a Three
Dog we'd all have been brainwashed by
the unclaimed a long time ago or eaten
by super mutants thanks three dog there
once was a man named Richard Moreau a
doctor working in vault 8 he was
eventually exiled for murder he wandered
the way son until he met Harold a fellow
wanderer and trader and that's where
Richard's life start again a bit weird
him and Harold were exposed to the
forced evolutionary virus a weird
mutating goop that the US government
were using to experiment on humans and
both were turned into gross flesh
abominations Harold became a ghoul
eventually growing a tree out of his
head and becoming the focus of a tree
minder cult but Richard was different
transforming intimate amorphous blob
that could absorb other beings and
merges cell
knology by doing this Richard now
calling himself the master and creating
an army of super mutants to serve him
using the fev aims to turn every human
in the world to one of his minions for
Humanity's along good good news for
everyone who's not keen on being a
sterile super mutant the master was
destroyed as part of the main quest of
fallout 1 bye-bye blob man Robert Edwin
house was born to a rich family in 2020
but often just a few years later when
his parents died in a freak autogyro
lightning accident he was cheated out of
his inheritance by his half-brother but
after attending MIT and founding robco
industries at the tender age of 22 he
started making money in the millions
over the years he gained power over a
number of other businesses rep con
aerospace the lucky 38 casino in New
Vegas and his own family business the
H&H Tool Company which made robotics but
once you've tasted money and power you
don't want to give them up and so mr.
house built himself machines to keep his
body and mind alive long past their
sell-by dates by the time you find him
he's 261 years old and he's the only
reason new vegas is still standing I
don't want to have to say money is power
but yeah if house was an ultra-rich he'd
have been bone dust like the rest of us
a long time ago but if you're really
talking influential players that changed
cause of the world we can't do so
without mentioning Benny sure he might
not be the nicest guy in New Vegas but
nice guys finish last after all without
Benny and his scheming you'd never
become the revenge-seeking courier of
new vegas legend we'd never have made
your mark on the factions of the mojave
and you would never have had the chance
to crucify a man by which I mean Benny
of course you'd also never have been
shot in the head so swings and
roundabouts penny used you as a pawn in
his quest to take over New Vegas making
sure that you were unable to deliver the
platinum chip to mr. house and thus
making it easier for him to seize
control of himself but Benny didn't
count on you surviving and becoming a
very angry courier rather than food for
the vultures so even though he did sort
of try to kill you we have him to thank
for the whole of Fallout New Vegas
thanks Benny our final influential
character is so important that they were
voted TIME's Person of the Year in two
thousand
no it's not bono that's 2005 it's you
the player the vault dweller the chosen
one the lone wanderer the courier you've
played all these roles and you've
changed the wasteland irreversible
you've saved vault 13 you defeated the
bad guys and destroyed the Enclave seat
of power in California you activated
project purity in Washington providing
its citizens with clean water and
sacrificing yourself in the process and
you define the future of the mojave by
siding with one of the factions in
nevada all in a day's work for the son
or daughter of liam neeson really how
influential your character will be in
fallout 4 is yet to be seen but your
quest could range from saving your
family village or city to taking down
the Institute repairing political
relations or saving the world of course
it could all turn out to just be a story
about how one man goes to walk his dog
around Boston
pretty girls are well you know that I'm
around cuz I'm a water
Oh
hey guys here comes the part of the show
where we check out some of the awesome
creations from the community i'm joined
by kate today what's up so if you want
to send in your own creations make sure
you use the hashtag GS fallout we've had
some awesome submissions already so
we're going to check them out first up
we have some Skyrim vault boys from our
onimous 7z this was submitted for the
hashtag cheers for that stuff it's
amazing they've recreated Skyrim
characters inside a fallout look at that
and what they've done is they put it in
a book as if you're going to reference
this book you're gonna be like who's
this man is trying to stab me you get
your book out and you go oh he's that
guy yeah got it in the bit boy so you
can pretend you're in the world the
wastes or they've got it in a tome h 0
at 0 is this not just a book when it's
fantasy is it no it was attached to be
at home and then you can just speak me
wandering around Skyrim as well and be
like I want to be a bit blowing man
mm-hmm next up we have fallout props by
Xander you're a me so these are pretty
loving me made I think I mean the
attention to detail oh yeah it's like
he's made an entire shish kebab we're
like a well not a real motorcycle tanks
i'm pretty sure that would be heavy on
the spine yeah it looks dangerous it all
looks pretty dangerous this looks
dangerous i would not be wanting to
drink this why did you get all the dust
from i think it just it looks like you
just buried them for a bit and then you
ready they're done and if you get
addicted to the fallout 4 show yeah and
take some fixer so what's in fixer
exactly I'm not sure all I know is that
if you drink too much whiskey in New
Vegas you should take some fixed nai all
right crack on the future is great isn't
it future is fixed and because it's the
end of October now I thought I'd find
some Halloween pumpkins or fallout based
oh yeah God awesome super kurama yet
that's a really good one and of course
the vault boy be easy to you maybe we
should do one of these in Yoshi's to
make a massive mess you know i I've
never carved a pumpkin cuz it looks I
don't think I don't think we're gonna do
a job as well as that that looks amazing
I feel like that would just fall apart a
mysterious stranger will try to cover
their face with like Oh David caved in
hey bro the pumpkin
ok me have to go bye pumpkin then okay
so me and Kate or after buy a pumpkin
thank you so much for watching everyone
out there make sure you like the video
and subscribe to the fallout 4 show stay
tuned to gamespot for more fallout 4
goodness I'm happy Halloween that and we
will see you next time West London
you